Caitlyn Jenner and Sophia Hudgens thank
you for joining us on Entertainment
Tonight in an unprecedented time my
first question for both of you which
we're asking everybody is just how are
you holding up and what are you doing to
stay safe right now first of all thank
you for having us do this it was an
excuse to get dressed to actually pick
yourself up and actually it's like we're
working this is wonderful well we've
been basically at home we're facing
within the family we're facing a lot of
challenges but we've been sticking it
out you know staying home quarantine is
not the best but we're doing it you know
we're all getting through it I think
like because we live on a mountain we
can go out and walk the dogs walk the
trails so that's been really nice
because no one's around yeah yeah it's
been fun talk just physical activity I
think is the best way we've been getting
through it yeah and the dogs are very
happy because we're here every day by
the way did you both do your own hair
and makeup for this as I did cuz you
look great yes we do wonderful I
wondered with you Caitlyn because I know
you or someone who has been so amazing
at doing your nails always and I am not
used to it you have any tips ah my my
nail person that I usually use Jason
they're not taking anybody there so it's
been a while yeah I don't know I haven't
done it myself yet I haven't gotten that
bad you know for the family and
everything because since everybody's you
know poor Jeanne yeah thank God for you
know FaceTime you can kind of keep in
contact with everybody I know I talked
to Kendall this morning she's hiding out
in Palm Springs
you know kinase at home you know all the
kids my son Brandon who just a little
over a month ago had twins you know
FaceTime them so that's really the only
time I haven't seen him in a while you
know it's kind of scary but I see him
every day on pay
yeah I was wondering that I mean how are
you guys cuz I know they all live a
little bit closer to each other and you
guys are a little bit further away so
has your contact with your kids been
solely FaceTime and how regularly are
you keeping in touch with everybody to
stay close right now pretty much every
day we FaceTime each other
and see how her what he's doing you know
my mom just 93 Wow I you know talk to
her everyday
you know obviously she's up in Idaho but
she's at a high risk you know but it's
been the whole thing has been kind of
devastating last week last weekend I was
in London all of the travel restrictions
were coming up they said if Monday I
think at noon they were gonna at
midnight they were going to stop traffic
you know coming in from London so I had
to switch boys get on a quicker flight I
missed two days of work I was supposed
to work Monday and Tuesday there you
know and get home and sopia it's the
same way with their company yeah we had
to send everyone at Loomis all work from
home we converted our guesthouse into
our office space and it's been crazy
because you're so used to working we're
launching April 1st and you know that's
been put on hold we were at Coachella
obviously Coachella was postponed so
we've just been like one blow after
another with work but you know that's
the least of our worries
we're healthy all of our friends and
family are healthy and um you know we're
just getting through it we did this
first and foremost for my employees and
of course our future customers social
distancing right now is extraordinarily
important so it didn't make sense for us
to do a digital launch backed with pop
up experiences in-store experiences we
need our customers our employees to say
stay safe yes Sophie you've had to put
some of your business projects on hold
right yeah so we were supposed to launch
Limassol the SPF company that I log that
I started on April 1 and we were
supposed to follow it up with pop-ups
both weekend's of Coachella and that
was heartbreaking because we've been
working on it for two years turning up
here Sofia's been in this so we've had
this launch date forever and I know
everything is up in the air it's like I
know what we're gonna go on we're fine
and but it's just like oh that was
unexpected well right and and we're all
adjusting I'm glad to hear you're both
doing well Kaitlyn you mentioning
Kendall and Kylie how are they doing
are you able to face time with the
grandkids too yeah no actually they're
doing very well I think
Kylie's happy because she's at home and
spending a lot of time with stormy and
she loves that Kendall as you know a
couple of friends out in Palm Springs
and so yeah everybody's kind of coping
with it I think from a financial
standpoint the economic impact that this
is having on our countries is obviously
huge and we just have to you know
realize that the health of our company
our country is much more important and
suck it up business-wise and you know
when things stop and things come Oakley
back to normal at some point we'll fire
everything up again so right now
everybody's just leg and low I think
making more phone calls with friends I
haven't talked to its mom it's been
actually kind of fun yeah I know I feel
like we're all kind of resetting and
actually having really long
conversations with people for the first
time in a while um and even you
mentioned Kylie I mean I think fans have
always gotten a sense of even from
watching on the show that kindly kind of
was already a bit of a homebody so would
you say she's doing the best in all this
or who's doing okay who you had to kind
of counsel more if anything I think
Kylie said that pregnancy prepared her
yeah quarantine and I think that that
was so funny that she said that and I
think that's so accurate I think that
that couldn't speak better you know she
couldn't sit I've said it better herself
yeah yeah oh they're doing they're doing
fine kylie is come on body Kendall likes
getting out
but she loves being at home she loves
cooking lesbian you know with a little
stormy and she's doing just fine
I think what's a little scary about this
time is we all worry about everyone we
love in our lives like you're worried
about your parents because they're older
you're worried about you know your kids
because you we can't protect each other
right now and and I wonder how that
feels for you guys with your own
families as a parent d do you feel that
sense of worry and how are you kind of
keeping yourselves mentally in a good
place as we're all trying to do
well I'm very positive I've always been
that way I always look at the positive
side today yeah these types of things
and I try to remake that with my kids
okay this is not the end of the world we
will get through this
I've been around a long time I've been
through Ebola viruses I've been through
all of these types of things and you
know for some of the kids that are
actually very young this may be the
first time they've been through a real
scare like this and you have to take it
seriously but it often has to be
optimistic because we always get through
these things it's not easy but we always
get through these things so you know
enjoy your time off enjoy your time with
your family one Caitlyn I mean I'm
talking to an Olympian here and the
Olympics are now totally up in the air
what did you think when you heard the
news of that decision well obviously we
have to do what's right and I think
they're probably doing was right by
postponing it a year but from an athlete
standpoint it's devastating
I mean you trained like when I was
training I trained those four years to
compete on the 29th and 30th of July in
1976 and all my training was all geared
towards that the peak at those on those
days and for the athletes out there all
of a sudden you throw this in and now
they don't even know when they're going
to compete so it's it's difficult yeah
it's difficult remember in 1980 we
boycotted
and I was devastated for that
fortunately I had retired at that time
but here the exactly's had trained for
four years and then we don't even go you
know yeah yeah it could be devastating
for an athlete yeah right I I mean once
for some of these athletes this might
have been their last chance right I mean
you can only push your body to these
lengths for so long right I was very
fortunate I knew I was gonna retire at
the games that was gonna be my last meet
and then I was kind of moving on in life
but what if I had not want what if I had
said okay you know I didn't you know I
should have but I didn't maybe I should
go another four years and train for
three and a half years and then you
don't even go that would have been
devastated yeah it would have been very
very difficult well I love seeing you
guys sitting so close to each other and
making sure that you're taking care of
each other I don't know about you but
I'm finding new realms of my own
relationships and now in terms of giving
each other space and that kind of thing
what is it looking for you during the
day how are you kind of making sure
you're getting in good time in
communication but do you ever separate
and have to say I'm gonna go in this
room for a minute now
nodding emphatically I think is big
enough so we can kind of do our own
thing but I'm working all day like my
work hasn't stopped I'm on zoom' all day
like this
so my routine is a little more rigid and
structured but kaitlin's is a lot more
free so Caitlin's like out in the day
with the dogs exercising you come at the
beach with the dogs you know just laying
low but I'm like here working and then I
just stick to my routine we both have
our own lives we both have our own
routines um but I know for me I'm just
like I need a vodka right now and I need
to like chill by myself and I need to
watch The Real Housewives of Beverly
Hills without you in the room yeah we're
very close we communicate we've been
through first we went through
the Wolsey fire two years ago when our
house we thought burned down but we
couldn't live here for a month so we're
you Santa Anas one time but put it this
way right now all my cars are clean the
garage is clean okay
the closets have been totally
reorganized having been through yeah I
mean the fires I've been talking about
that yeah I'm in Westlake Village right
now I'm not too far from you guys and
you know man you think about how
everything just the people in some of
these areas of the country have been
through the past couple of years what
has that taught you guys about your
relationship about how you communicate
each other with each other in terms of
like maybe what to advise people on
here's how you can stick together and
get through a tough time like this from
what you were I think what you really
need is really good friends close people
that are close to you good friends that
you can you know share your feelings
with I would say the most important part
is compromise you need to be able to
compromise and listen to one another
these things are so scary like no I'm a
control freak
I want everything disinfected I want the
security system like I want the new fire
systems I want everything like I'm so
over prepared and Caitlin's like and
we'll get through it and I'm like no no
no no no no no but I think really with
us because our personalities are so
different and we're living under one
roof it's all about compromise and
listening to one another and that and
yeah playing with the dogs is really
stressed or anything actually you
mentioned Real Housewives of Beverly
Hills I mean I can't wait for that
premiere the New York premiere what
shows are you guys binge watching our
movies that are maybe like getting you
through the house boredom so anything
that is an issue with the family nature
issue
Caitlin watches car shows and golf all
day okay and I am only into like
newest show so I'm right now binging old
episodes of Real Housewives of Beverly
Hills because I had actually never
watched it until just starting this
season I was going way back but we don't
watch this thing stop it okay hold on
can I dream cast would you guys ever be
on Real Housewives of Beverly Hills I
would be on in two seconds
actually I did watch an episode I did
watch an episode with you like two
nights ago forced you I know you forced
me and I honestly kind of got into it
you know I've done reality television
know I've done reality television pretty
much all my life I mean starting all the
way back sports is reality television
yeah you don't know what's gonna happen
there's no script you go out and do it
and I was watching that and I was
thinking you know what okay I can see
myself getting in there with some of the
drama yeah I can see that yeah yeah
those would be an injection into that
show that Andy Andy loved it
um well new season of Kardashian's
coming up soon I do will you watch all
of that or what does it like right yeah
your horse will watch it yeah Joe
obviously but yeah she's not doing the
show anymore right hiding I saw the
trailer that um Kristin Chloe posted
today and I thought it was funny I don't
know yeah I know I did
funny I'm excited to see it it's a well
and look we're all like on our phones on
our screens non-stop right now - I know
you know Kim was getting into a mix of
stuff on Twitter I'm like it's there I I
never know what's gonna happen with your
kids Catelynn they're always giving me
new things to to intake I don't know
it's sad when you get to the point where
you gotta find out what your kids are
doing on Instagram or social media or
the show or any of that kind of stuff I
it's a shame that I've kind of lost
contact from that
standpoint what you know I have been
very all about us you have not lost I'm
lost and point but I am so proud of all
the kids they have just amazed me over
the years you know I tried to bring him
up you know being you know taking risks
and going out there being very
entrepreneurial but I never expected
that they would go as far as they did
they're smart hard-working kids and I
couldn't be more proud of them well and
I know you guys you both just posted on
your instagrams about charities you want
people to know about as all of this
Korona pandemic continues is there
anything you want to spotlight and make
sure that people reach out their hands
to if they can I think the one I posted
about I felt really strongly I'm about
was food for young children that are not
in school right now and so many young
people especially in LA Unified are low
income and they rely on reduced or free
lunch and for me giving and supporting
that organization was super important
you know we know so many different
people that Brendon education system
teachers like so many teams from
teachers or you know principals from all
over the world saying thank you this
message needs to get out so many kids
rely on this and so for me that was my
charity of choice during this time just
because no one's in school you know very
blessed to live in this country we have
the best medical system in the world
we'll figure this thing out we'll take
care of our people but you have to
realize if this virus goes to other
areas of the world it could be
devastating and we have to keep that in
mind
you know we're very blessed to live here
you know
but if you're in Africa or you're
someplace and this virus comes in um it
could be absolutely devastating well
thank you guys so much for sharing so
much um I am so glad to hear that maybe
your reality TV careers aren't over so
yeah really
this is really possible we never know
right um Kaitlyn Kaitlyn of youth I mean
I feel like in this time we're all using
this time to you know maybe get creative
or or take more time to do things we
haven't before have you thought about
like you know writing a book again or
like anything else that you would
continue to share with the world
well no I've thought about over the last
five years I've been through a lot and
there's I think a lot more to tell about
my my story my life and the issues that
are out there I think at the beginning I
really didn't know much about the trans
community about the environment I was
getting into made some mistake said some
things and I didn't think we're bad but
then all of a sudden things change and I
just feel like I kind of have a lot to
say so that is one thing that I've
thought about is where we are today you
know over you know the last few years I
started my own foundation and then I
worked with Mac on raising money I was
able to raise a lot of money and give it
away to great trans organizations and
stop them you know I'd like to continue
to do that and just kind of do my part
use my platform which is different than
in most cases but use that platform you
know to help out some well I know that
we'd all love to hear more from you and
wait Sophia was that'd be careful could
do you manage Caitlyn right now is that
part of the really managing Caitlyn
[Music]
January 2000 and no yeah 2018 yeah so
what's that like to work together and be
under one roof easy so yeah my words
final I'm gonna say hey you're doing
this this and this and Kaitlyn's gonna
say great I'm gonna say okay the check
cleared let's do it it's interesting
it's fun but it's good because there's
like always a constant line of
education yeah so you know managing her
is like half of my job and the other
half is running my company right and I
really like it because it's kind of like
I get the best of both worlds and it's
been great I love it ya know Sophia is
extraordinarily smart extraordinarily
capable of
I mean she's done with luma so it
started off with an idea in the bedroom
cuz I had cancer issues on my face from
sun exposure and I just said to her okay
go do it and that was two-and-a-half
years and she raised millions of dollars
she went out to venture capital and so
smart and so good and so respected by
the venture capital world it's been an
amazing process I had all the products
made had you know the SPF product made
our dispensers made and we have what
five six employees like eighteen amazing
job
kaitlin's very very supportive is like
how's it going how can I help you and
I'm like you know what it's going good
let me spare you the details but
whatever yeah whenever I need any
support or help yeah optionally
personally my therapist over here I love
hearing that because we all need a we
all need as much comfort and support as
we can get right now um now did you say
be careful to Kaitlyn cuz some things in
the works I can't oh my goodness but I
think with us this business is all about
reinventing yourself coming out with a
new project we always have things up our
sleeves that we're working on and you
know you'll just have to stay tuned
love it and hopefully stay tuned to you
both on the Real Housewives of Beverly
Hills this is there you go I know do you
have a do you have a favorite when you
guys are watching Oh
- Lisa can't Lisa run out hands down I'm
always posting dancing videos with like
you know Lisa Rinna in spike and she's
no I like Lisa I've known her for years
and years and years and that's your way
in
somebody that constantly reinvents
herself and always continues to work I
think she's done an amazing job yeah and
she's funny and fun and well and Cohen
always says the best casting starts with
a real relationship so there you go I
don't know do you know any of the other
ladies who have been on the show oh you
know a lot of them I only ELISA you know
Denise right yes I don't yeah
you're friends with Maurice yeah yeah no
all right guys I'm just you know in the
corona times we just got to get creative
and we're gonna make some stuff happen
well I'll get it wrong get through this
I guarantee we so thank you both for
making the time to talk to us anything
else you want to mention that we didn't
get a chance to get to thank you for you
know giving us an excuse to get dressed
you both
you look great honestly I'm like this is
the eye makeup on both of you poppin
right now so thank you setting the bar
all right we'll let you guys go thank
you stay safe of course at home and
thanks for setting a good example for
everybody we appreciate you thank you
thanks hi